today's movie business compared to let's
say 50 years ago 60 years ago let me
compare it to something a little earlier
which is the studio system in nineteen
late 20s and early 30s um when people
had seven year contracts and vast
numbers of people were employed and
there was a kind of trade identity and a
kind of security about the business that
was in many ways beneficial and which
kind of sustained American filmmaking
was what made American movies different
than European films because the European
films even back then were more organized
the way we do it now pick up a company
you get some people together to find the
script you find a producer you put it
together to do it once and it's all over
that's that was basically prevailing
European model for many years you know
the studio system I sense not having
been there but for what I hear about it
was a big family and people felt happy
and secure working for it and took a
kind of pride in doing a kind of workmen
like job which is a difference of head
remember running into a wonderful old
director years ago and I said to him
what's your greatest sense of
accomplishment he said I always brought
my movies in on time and I always my
movies always made money and it was
great and that was my satisfaction was
no talk and that about heart or soul or
character I think so was a different
kind of perspective in a more
industrially oriented of you know
sustaining environment that's different
now when we meet people and pick up
groups and shoot whatever we can shoot
it's some really much more fragmentary
kind of life I think and it was for
filmmakers back in the golden days of
the studio and I guess they felt um
sustained by it was hard work hours and
so on but there was
kind of secure identity that I think
they had that we often don't anymore and
then things changed and how well when
the city has broke up in the 50s that
was a really sort of crucial break point
for movie history you know when stars
instead of producers were sort of in
control and people running their own
contracts and financing their own movies
for better or worse things changed in
when studios lost their distribution
arms and they're exhibiting theaters
things changed and better worse it's
different great things happens but it's
different
you